entre minsk y bruselas se lanzan
amenazas cruzadas y las tensiones se
escalan hasta límites inexplorados el
ministro alemán en funciones aseguró que
los 27 del bloque europeo determinarán
nuevas sanciones contra belarús el
próximo lunes
22 que en el pasado dijimos que
demasiadas sanciones contra belarús
favorecerían que el país dependiera más
de rusia sin embargo hemos llegado un
punto donde las consecuencias deben ser
más claras por lo que considero que
áreas económicas de importancia como la
industria de la russa del potasio debe
ser sancionada una idea mayoritaria en
el seno de la unión europea
amenazas a las que alexander lukashenko
presidente de belarús no ha tardado en
responder apuntando contra la debilidad
de europa el gas
hemos aumentado los volúmenes de gas
natural bombeado a través de belarús el
oleoducto llamada europa está lleno
estamos calentando a europa y amenazan
con cerrar la frontera y si bloqueamos
el suministro de gas natural a jing la
crónica crisis entre minsk y bruselas se
agravó esta vez por la llegada de
emigrantes a las puertas polacas de
europa la unión acusa a lukashenko de
promover la migración clandestina hacia
territorio comunitario como arma
desestabilizadora en contrapartida a mí
enseñada a la unión europea por no
asumir las consecuencias de su política
exterior y por incumplir tratados
internacionales como la convención de
ginebra tensiones diplomáticas que
mantienen a cientos de personas
bloqueadas en los bosques invernales del
este de europa un escenario que las
autoridades de naciones unidas- ya han
calificado de catástrofe humanitaria
hacemos un llamado a todos los estados
involucrados a prestar atención al
contexto humanitario de esta situación y
a resolverla de forma humana
según el medio polaco 'gazeta wyborcza'
al menos 10 personas han muerto en la
zona limítrofe siete de ellas en
territorio de polonia